[Music]
the Apple watch is a huge release for
the company it's the first new product
they've made since the iPad and the
death of Steve Jobs the first new
product created entirely under the watch
of CEO Tim Cook and the first one that
Johnny I've the star designer and Apple
has really created from the inside out
it is a fascinating beautiful device but
nobody really knows if it's any good
well I've had one for a week and I can
tell you if it's any good
[Music]
the watch is gorgeous in a surgical
sterile sci-fi kind of way but it is a
digital watch and several people pointed
out to me that it reminded them of
Cassio's calculator watch which was very
popular in the 80s
it also looks a little bit like other
smart watches on the market namely
Samsung's Galaxy gear if I were looking
at the Apple watch in a jewelers case
next to an Omega and a Rolex and a
Breitling I don't know if I'd
necessarily choose Apple's version over
the others but after wearing it for a
week or so I have started to get
comfortable with it and maybe even liked
it a little bit just like any Apple
product it's not about good looks alone
this thing is packed full of advanced
technology for instance the display has
a new type of pressure sensitivity the
company calls forced touch which
responds to not just where you press on
the display but how hard you press also
when you get a notification on the watch
you feel an intense buzzing and
sometimes almost like a tapping of a
bell and that's thanks to the taptic
engine which controls vibrations on the
watch but most importantly there's the
digital crown which is a new
navigational method Apple's created that
mimics the crown on a regular watch but
you use it on the Apple watch for moving
through lists selecting options in apps
and zooming in and out of photos and
maps it's a pretty incredible package
and in my opinion the most advanced
piece of wearable technology you can buy
right now but of course the Apple watch
is also a watch and it does the job of
telling you the time just sometimes not
when you want to
you see there are sensors in the Apple
watch that tell it when to turn on the
screen and when to turn off the screen
sometimes when you bring it up to your
face to check on the time it works
perfectly but every once in a while it
doesn't turn on and that can be
completely maddening when you just want
to know what time it is
fun fact Apple uses something called
coordinated Universal time to keep all
of its watches in sync it's extremely
precise and if you're in a room full of
Mickey Mouse faces all of the Mickey
feet are tapping in sync but of course
the watch is more than a watch it's
actually really powerful but learning
how to use it can take a little time
that's for two reasons the first is that
there's just a lot of new ways to
interact with the watch like the digital
crown the second is that the watch
extends and sometimes replicates the
functions of your phone at first I was
having a kind of internal battle over
whether I should check a notification on
the watch or on the phone but that got
better with time just like the phone the
watch gets every notification that comes
through to you that means every email
every text message every Twitter message
pings the watch the way it pings your
phone if you're really busy and you're
talking to people a lot that becomes
overwhelming really fast what I realize
is that you really have to call your
notifications and think about what's
most important eventually I got to a
place where only the most important
notifications hit my watch and
everything else went to the phone in
some ways and I'm sure Apple would not
love to hear this
the watch is sort of a miniature phone
on your wrist you can make calls with it
you can send text messages with it you
can get navigation on it in fact it does
a lot of what your phone does but there
are a few features that are brand-new to
the watch and brand-new for Apple some
of these new features are great like the
activity app which gives you this very
low pressure low effort way of tracking
your exercise all day long I found
myself using this a lot and looking at
it a lot and thinking about whether or
not I was very healthy or terribly
unhealthy spoiler alert
terribly unhealthy what is great about
the Apple watch though is that it's got
these little widgets on the display
called complications those can be things
that tell you the weather or what
your next appointment is or the phases
of the Moon I actually found them really
useful they're one of my favorite things
about the watch and it did make me
wonder why we don't have any of those
things on the iPhone homescreen but some
features are decidedly less successful
like the ability to send your heartbeat
to somebody this is cool if it's your
wife or girlfriend but it seems weird to
send your heartbeat to anybody else and
once you've done it one time well you've
done it all so you can sketch things out
on the watch and send them to other
watch wearers but the screens only an
inch and a half so my sketches were
mostly limited to weird faces and
question works apples also introduced a
set of 3d animated emojis which I'm
sorry to say are less expressive and
interesting than regular old emojis
finally there's something called glances
that Apple is offering up as a new way
to get information quickly on the watch
you swipe up from the bottom and you get
a set of little cards and on those cards
there's single serving pieces of
information like the latest tweet your
timeline or your heartbeat I kind of
wanted to love these but the problem is
they're inconvenient they're hidden and
they often have to load from the phone
so you don't get the information right
away you get a spinning wheel I think
they could be good with time but they
need a lot of work one of the things I
struggled with while using the watch was
how much I looked at it and how much I
looked at it while I was in a group
setting or talking to somebody it can be
very rude in mid-sentence to look down
and check your watch it's just as rude
if not more rude than looking at your
phone if you're thinking that the Apple
watch is gonna solve your distraction
problem or fix notifications in your
life it's not going to you've got to do
that it's a question of self control
ultimately the watch is not life
changing I don't even know if it's game
changing it is a really beautiful really
well-designed really effective Apple
product and if you love Apple products
and use a bunch of them this is a great
companion but it's not going to make you
a better person or change your life or
change how you look at the world it's a
great accessory and maybe that's enough
you